[Music]
when the me2 movement first took off and
we were getting women coming forward and
telling their stories of harassment
assault or discrimination in their
workplace we're like this is the only a
matter of time before we get some really
good stories coming out financial
industry because we know that it exists
Wall Street just like lots of areas has
some serious and pretty deep problems
but you know a big cultural moment it
has not happened now to the me2 movement
growing this morning in the wake of the
Harvey Weinstein scandal high-powered
men across entertainment media
technology and politics have been
brought down by women who felt empowered
to tell their stories but on Wall Street
a system of silence has protected the
status quo the primary difference for
women on Wall Street versus other
industries is money and money is power
and Wall Street has the most money and
the most power of any industry you know
story by story it's like we get this
peek into this machine you know
different arms of the machine those arms
explain why there was no revolution in
finance this year instead there were
rare moments of Revelation that pierced
the silence keeping people quiet doesn't
make it better for the business you
don't hire the best people if you
exclude people who are brave this is the
story of the forces that have kept the
me to reckoning from hitting Wall Street
at least so far women didn't want to
come forward with their stories they
didn't want to go on the record women I
talked to actually didn't even want to
name the people that had assaulted them
or hurt their careers in a particular
way and we kind of had to take a step
back and say why is that happening and
evaluate what is the culture and Wall
Street or the system in Wall Street
that's keeping women from doing that you
know there is a machine of silence that
we've learned about that has to do with
arbitration and human resources and
public relations
and a culture of fear and a culture of
money and all those things together
combined to create kind of a wall
between allegations and transparency
first of all you have this very
male-dominated industry about 26% of
senior executives on Wall Street are
women and that and when you get to the
CEO level it's it's abysmally low women
only make up 8% of CEOs at major
financial institutions and in the
history of Wall Street no woman has ever
led any of the 6 largest US banks
I remember Wall Street women saying to
me you know what do you think Wall
Street values they value relationships
and they value secrecy and they value
loyalty and if I dare to go against
those things I will be exiled and if
someone does decide to complain it isn't
done in public but rather hidden behind
a widespread system of arbitration
arbitration needs to be relabeled it
needs to be called forced silence
arbitration is a private system that
takes fights behind closed doors away
from a judge and jury it was originally
used to solve industry disputes but Wall
Street has helped it spread to all kinds
of fights including harassment civil
rights issues should be dealt with in
court civil rights issues should be
transparent that's Lee stole a Wall
Street veteran who's suing Cantor
Fitzgerald for harassment discrimination
and retaliation but that's just a part
of her fight she's also battling to stay
away from arbitration I want to go to
court because I want it to be
transparent it's not female thing it's
not a male thing it's a human thing
what's so wild for us as reporters
following least old story is that she
had not won but apparently to
arbitration agreements Cantor says it's
so basically she said yeah I can't I am
not supposed to be thrown out of court
I'm supposed to stay in this venue and
the court agreed with her Cantor denies
her allegations and is appealing the
decision to let her stay in court but
these days judges all the way up to the
Supreme Court have been siding with
arbitration from Wall Street's
perspective that system is quicker
cheaper quieter and just as fares
court women likely see it differently
for those of us who are not corporations
we want to be able to show the evidence
and we want to be able to change
behavior women are not learning about
each other they're being isolated from
each other so they can't really come
together and bring something bigger
against a bank or an institution and say
you have a major problem here because
it's all in this hush-hush system that
nobody knows about while Lee was
fighting against arbitration women
thousands of miles away were struggling
to have their stories heard inside
Lloyds of London Lloyd's is a three
hundred thirty one-year-old exchange for
the worldwide insurance market that's
steeped in tradition of the work they're
still done face to face by mostly
middle-aged white men on paper and
sealed with rubber stamps but reporting
from bloomberg uncovered that Lloyd's
also has a deep-seated tradition of
sexual harassment respect to women who
had been attacked by their bosses in in
pubs and taxis you know and we'd spoken
to other women who were deluged with
text graphic text graphic emails from
the employers basically soliciting for
sex
what's so sinister about these stories
isn't just the picture they paint of
rich men behaving badly but the way HR
protected them at least in my experience
for the Wall Street firms most of the
time say that they simply can't go to HR
it's just not an option because if they
do HR is then going to report them to
either the exact mail that they just
complained about or somebody else
position to make things difficult but of
the ones who did go to HR they reported
being discouraged from pursuing their
complaints further they were warned
about possibility of being marked out as
difficult women so kept quiet
Boyd's first female CEO Inga Beale tried
to change that but she was met with
hostility including a death threat and
was eventually replaced by John Neill in
2018
Bloomberg's reporting hit a few months
later two executives at the company have
now resigned following allegations of
sexual harassment you know sometimes
when we're reporting on stories like
this you know companies just deny what
we find and say look everything is fine
in the case of Lloyd's gavin's reporting
was so powerful that the CEO of this
insurance market came out afterwards and
said yeah this is pretty much
unacceptable and we will change this is
not the Lloyds that I want to be part of
and not the Lloyds that many of my
colleagues feel they want to be part of
either Lloyd's unveiled a whistleblower
hotline banned alcohol and announced a
lifetime ban for sexual harassers
whether there is any long-term impact
from these measures it's too early I
think to tell
and while the Loyd story showed how
women stories can help bring an
antiquated institution into the 21st
century a conference in California
showed what happens when the industry's
bystanders break their silence everyone
it's Alex leaking just got back from the
Tiburon CEO summit dinner in October of
2019 Alex Chilean who runs a firm called
Lake Avenue financial was attending a
conference and did something unheard of
on Wall Street he publicly spoke out
against someone at an invite-only
conference things that were said by Ken
Fisher were just absolutely horrifying
he made comments about genitalia talked
about picking up on a girl and don't
show him what's in your pants and
shortly after Bloomberg reporter Sabrina
Wilmer was able to speak to Ken Fisher
on the phone his initial reaction is
that he didn't think it was a big deal
because he's been saying this a very
long time and nobody has questioned it
ken Fischer was speaking in a way that
he was used to speaking which was gross
quite frankly I don't know if I could
but if I was thirty years old and I had
to do over again I'd have more sex
well like while I could while I could
once you get older you know once you get
older you know you're like a Christmas
tree you know you're your firm once a
year and the balls are just for
decoration but instead of awkward
laughter behind closed doors
this year Fisher's institutional clients
from Texas to New Hampshire yanked about
four billion dollars from his investment
firm Fisher CEO Damien or Nani even went
directly in front of a Los Angeles
pension board to apologize
[Music]
but for pension board members like Brian
Pendleton that apology wasn't enough I'm
incredibly proud of what the LA Police
and Fire pension Commission did by
decisively terminating the contract with
Ken Fisher that I hopefully sends a loud
message to the financial community while
about four billion dollars was lost the
firm still manages a hundred fifteen
billion dollars and the company has said
that since the incident their assets
have actually grown we talked to each
other inside the newsroom you know we
asked is this is much changes we're
gonna see it's plausible that this is as
far from the status quo as things are
gonna veer and things will get back to
business as usual I'm not in favor of
outing other women but I will say that
women have reached out to me and told me
that we need to keep this going I'm not
I'm certainly the drop in the bucket to
the issue and the only way to change
that is for a couple of people to stand
up and I'm hopeful that other people
will stand next to me we're never going
to stop trying to tell women's stories
what we can hope for is that the
industry is moving in the direction in
which more women feel comfortable
telling their stories
[Music]
you